à mon commandement en joue c'est parti
pour l'exposition les armes savante
l'histoire de l'équipement de l'armée
française des navires du xviiie siècle à
l'artillerie lourde jusqu au pistolet de
lempire versailles au coeur de
l'innovation militaire on a ici un
coffret tout à fait unique qui a
appartenu à napoléon 1er donc c'est un
coffret avec deux pistolets et tout le
nécessaire d'entretien et de tirs et
donc on a des armes qui sont
caractéristiques du style de nicolas
noël boutet qui est le directeur de la
manufacture d'armes de versailles
le public va pouvoir découvrir des
choses assez assez variés des armes de
l'ancien régime mais du premier empire
donc des choses extrêmement travaillé
avec parfois un côté excellence dans le
luxe parfois un côté excellence dans
l'innovation par rapport à ce qui se
fait à l'époque d'alors des casernes
plusieurs régiments et des écoles
militaires versailles et satori
deviennent des lieux de développement du
matériel de l'armée française on a des
bureaux de conception on a des
développeurs qui sont présents à
versailles en grande particularité sur
le plateau de satory
et puis on a des expérimentateurs la
section technique de l'armée de terre
est installé à satory depuis le milieu
des années 1800 soit 1900 par dont 70
les plus on a des industriels de la
défense des industriels comme le groupe
nexter à l'origine de ces munitions ou
encore du canon caesar utilisé notamment
par l'armée française en afghanistan
l'équipement militaire c'est aussi
protéger les soldats sur les opérations
cette technologie elle permet aux
fantassins embarqué dans un véhicule
blindé
en cas de contact avec un engin explosif
improvisé
on va dire absorbé l'effet de souffle
produit par cet engin l'effet de souffle
ne va pas être absorbé par le corps du
soldat mais par le siège
l'ensemble de ces objets ont été prêtés
notamment par le musée des armées le
groupe nexter ou encore les archives
communales de versailles une exposition
à découvrir jusqu'au 9 décembre à
l'espace richaud